c'était un petit bricoleur besogneux
que ces rames est capable d'idées
géniales hiver 1954 la france grelotte
dans la rue des gens meurent de froid
face à ces drames et l'inaction de la
classe politique un homme lance un appel
au secours à la radio c'était le 1er
février 1954 il ya 68 ans cet homme
s'appelle henri grouès plus connu sous
le nom abbé pierre il vaut que ce soir
même dans toutes les villes de prendre
des pancartes s'accroche où l'on lise
ces simples mots toi qui souffrent qui
que tu sois entre dort mange reprend
espoir ici on t'aime antoine sueur
président d'emmaüs revient sur cet élan
de solidarité aussi appeler à
l'insurrection de la bonté il avait un
contact à rtl où s'est précipité en
suivant il faut que le monde sache il
faut que le monde sache et comment le
monde peut-il le savoir aussi vite que
par une radio à l'époque dans l'après
guerre la france manque de logements en
région parisienne des familles entières
s'entassent dans des bidonvilles
chaque nuit at il dit ils sont plus de
2000 recroquevillé sur le gel à la rue
sans toit sans pain plus d'un presque
nue c'est ce contexte là qui a fait que
l'abbé pierre autour de la question du
logement s'est révolté jusqu'à
maintenant c'était un grand d accord
social mais là c'était une révolte ce
qu'on a appelé à la révolte de la
charité la vague c est ce cri de
désespoir est entendue
dès le soir de l'appel un immense
mouvement de solidarité à paris et il a
eu du monde à son rendez-vous du
panthéon
dès le soir et paquets de couvertures de
vêtements afflué et ce ne sont pas
seulement des riches qui ont donné
quelque chose
il ya personne n'arrive à us - y compris
qui aurait cette capacité actuelle mais
la nouveauté des médias sa capacité à
l'utiliser à une petite habitude de se
mettre en scène aussi un petit peu
à tout ça a fait que ça a marché le
mouvement emmaüs existait depuis 1949
l'association a été officialisée en mars
1954 un mois seulement après l'appel de
l'abbé pierre grâce aux compagnons et
chiffonniers d'emmaüs ce sont les débuts
de l'économie solidaire il répare il
nettoie ils remettent dans le circuit
avec minutie il forçait les choses à
redevenir intéressant utile à d'autres
sur le logement sur l'insertion par le
travail sur l'économie de la
récupération sur toute une série de
problèmes comme ça il m'a eu cette
structure sur les années suivantes
l'abbé pierre continuera de venir en
aide aux plus démunis jusqu'à sa mort le
22 janvier 2007 c'était il ya 15 ans
toute atteinte à la dignité des gens
nécessite qu'on se lève l'abbé pierre
c'était une conscience
[Musique]